yeah that was a good play by bledsoe
driving into the drought of lap of cat
karl anthony towns gonna be zion hard to
the hole
a little spring in his step
[Music]
friendly fire
[Music]
got a little momentum going into the
fourth quarter zion with 10 points
seven rebounds and an impressive finish
to end the period
[Music]
i was on washington his second
williamson now with 14 points ingram
with 15
pelicans trying to get a transition
basket here's zion on the top
and the slam plus a foul
this ball he pushes it and then he gets
it back and
shot clock down to five the defense for
new orleans has been pretty solid
tonight and they force a turnover
here's bledsoe on the trailer with the
one-handed flush
pulling out the suns in new orleans
showing exactly how
gifted and talented he is explodes
bounce the finish
there goes that match
six point lead for the new orleans
palace
lewis takes it out to williamson rising
up
underneath that's just not fair
left hand here sometimes you don't even
need to say that
wow you're right doug
hit his head on the other side of the
backboard
reed scoop shot for nas no
vanderbilt blocked by williamson and the
zion saves it
[Music]
let's take a look at our energy power
plant jump up on his left side
heads up wow
that is definitely moved instead of just
well done by tyrese oh
zion goes quick everything oh he caught
a body
metoo underneath if i said uh-oh because
i've used her before
well i've been on the other end of uh-oh
man not supposed to be that big and
deliver the good
that was a good play by bledsoe driving
into the drought of lack of cotton
that he counts gonna be zion
[Applause]
a little spring in his step let's take a
look at our energy power play you see
look
he doesn't space all the way to the
corner he gets in bi sideline and this
right here
exploding over two really good athletes
in layman
and also car anthony towns that's
impressive
where ingram and zion have to have
chemistry
he goes quickly with it against thompson
[Music]
i mean i said it mark there's only one
body that ever starts to move and it's
never zion's
you just he's punishing you
goodness
sandranski just checked into the game
former washington
someone else makes someone else beat you
get it out of his hands
zion on the run on the nice dribble
going strong to the rack
hey joe what a finesse move you want to
see a damn body
then he exploded let's look at our
energy power play you see the gamble
by temple and he set his boy up for
failure don't worry about it brother we
all been there gafford
we all been there wow
elevation power explosion with the
finish
what up it's your boy adam lefkow did
you like that content i know you like
that content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleach report